While we wait for official Avengers 4 news
from the notoriously tight-lipped crew at
Marvel, here's a look at why Captain America
is crucial to the outcome of the war against
Thanos and whether he'll still be standing
when those end credits roll.
The biggest news to break regarding Captain
America since the epic final moments of Infinity
War came to us in the form of a quick goodbye
note tweeted by none other than Chris Evans
himself.
In only a few heartfelt words, Evans let the
whole world know that he would be putting
down his shield for good.
The tweet, which amassed several hundred thousand
likes within hours, read:
"Officially wrapped on Avengers 4.
It was an emotional day to say the least.
Playing this role over the last 8 years has
been an honor.
To everyone in front of the camera, behind
the camera, and in the audience, thank you
for the memories!
Eternally grateful."
Maybe we'll see a cameo or two down the road,
but, for all intents and purposes, it does
seem like this is the end for Steve Rogers.
Infinity War may have been one of the wildest
rides in cinema history, but Captain America's
role in it was actually fairly minor.
Sure, we got a fun "re-emergence" sequence
for Cap in the fight at the train station
in Edinburgh, and his attempt to rally a crew
of heroes together to defend the world against
bad guys was a crucial part of the plot.
But even if Captain America ultimately received
a decent amount of screen time, it did feel
a bit like he was being used to move the story
forward more than anything else.
“Earth just lost her best defender.
So we’re here to fight.
And if you want to stand in our way, we’ll
fight you too.”
The truth is, Captain America ended up having
a muted role in Infinity War.
The story had him stranded in the middle of
a sidebar conflict in Wakanda, while Iron
Man took front and center on Titan.
It stands to reason that this will set Steve
Rogers up to be a crucial element in the next
chapter, where we'll almost certainly see
more of Cap's storyline unfold.
Captain America: Civil War ended on a pretty
low note, and many fans were hoping for some
onscreen reconciliation between Steve Rogers
and Tony Stark in Infinity War.
In the end, the two didn't even share a scene.
“The Avengers broke up.
We’re toast.
Broke up?
Like a band?
like the Beatles?”
That's not to say that the folks behind the
scenes didn't try to fit it in.
Writer Stephen McFeely explained that in the
original drafts of the script, they had Steve
and Tony in the same room together.
Ultimately, however, he said:
"As many times as we wrote those scenes, it
became clear that this movie needed to be
propulsive and be about Thanos and what he
represented to the Avengers."
It may not have fit into Infinity War’s
plot, but there's no way these two aren't
sharing some screen time in Avengers 4.
Their long-anticipated reconciliation will
no doubt be a pivotal scene and one that,
sadly, paves the way for Cap's demise.
Because once that breach is healed, Cap's
character arc will be nearly complete.
Just like a few of the other key players in
the MCU, Captain America's story arc is in
desperate need of closure.
We've watched him rise up to lead the Avengers
before entering into a self-imposed exile,
only to resurface for Infinity War but the
character is still in need of a final act
to bring his story to an end.
The Russo brothers have been quiet about what
might happen after the third Avengers, only
suggesting that Infinity War was, quote:
"...the next chapter, so to speak, in his
specific story.
And there's been no talk about where we go
beyond that yet."
That comment could quite easily be used to
infer that after Infinity War there just isn't
much more left for Steve Rogers to do in the
MCU.
One way or another, he needs some closure.
“Family, stability the guy who wanted that
went into the ice 75 years ago.
I think someone else came out.”
The truth is, Steve Rogers doesn't really
have to die in Avengers 4 for his story arc
to wrap up, for Chris Evans to move on, and
for the universe to be saved.
The only thing that seems inevitable is that
the character won't be with us on a regular
basis during Phase 4 of the MCU.
How could this happen without a heart-wrenching
death scene?
Rogers just needs to pass the Captain America
torch on to a successor, which could just
as easily take place after an epic comeback
victory against the Mad Titan.
There's a lot to be said for quitting while
you’re ahead and how much further ahead
do you get than defeating Thanos?
There's no shortage of rumors floating about
regarding who could replace Steve Rogers as
Captain America.
Whether it's Bucky Barnes, Sam Wilson or even
a complete wildcard, chances are the mantle
of Captain America will be passed on.
The question is, will Steve Rogers live to
see the passing of the torch... or will it
be wrenched from his grasp by Thanos' hands?